et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
julien on dit bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec on porte parole du
rassemblement national soutient bien
évidemment de marine le pen on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour oriane bonjour monsieur 12
bonjour monsieur odoul d'abord on va
évidemment que parler du programme de la
campagne de marine le pen mais c'est le
50e jour aujourd'hui de la guerre en
ukraine des accusations de génocide de
crimes de guerre qui sont proférées
contre les russes ont entendu hier
marine le pen présenté son programme
quand la politique étrangère elle dit
que la russie peut redevenir un allié
elle prône un rapprochement stratégique
entre l'otan et la russie est ce qu'à
des conditions à tout ça sk mais des
conditions pour faire revenir la russie
dans le concert des nations évidemment
qu'ils aient des conditions la russie et
marine le pen a été très clair et la dit
très rapidement d'ailleurs ça a été
l'une des responsables politiques qui a
tout de suite dénoncé l'agression de
l'ukraine par l'armée de vladimir
poutine déjà il faut saluer la
résistance du peuple ukrainien la
résistance son patriotisme
sa foi en la liberté en ses valeurs son
indépendance marine le pen est une
comment dirais-je il est attaché à la
souveraineté territoriale souhaité
nationale donc elle défend la
souveraineté territoriale de l'ukraine
après il ya des conditions effectivement
pour que la russie puisse revenir dans
le concert des nations et pour que nous
puissions retrouver des relations
apaisées et normale avec une grande
puissance qui ne va pas disparaître la
russie il faudra composer avec elle il
faudra composer avec le peuple russe qui
ne doit pas devenir un ennemi advitam
eternam et qui doit devenir à terme un
partenaire mais vous savez l'allemagne
est redevenue un partenaire alors que
nous avons été en guerre trois fois
contre contre ce pays il faut comment
dirais je poussais la russie à revenir à
ta d'une négociation ça passe par des
sanctions et marine le pen est favorable
aux fonctions à condition qu'elle ne
sanctionne pas d'abord le peuple
français notamment sur le prix des
énergies
et surtout
retenir toujours le dialogue est ce que
fait toutes les sanctions actuelles il
faut rester mesuré il faut avoir quand
même je dirais la boussole et c'est le
ce que je souhaite marine le pen
l'intérêt national d'intérêt juste un
dernier mot parce qu'on n'a pas bien
compris les conditions un moment marine
le pen parler de vladimir poutine comme
d'un alien un peu changé discours
maintenant elle parle de la russie à ce
que la condition pour qu'ils reviennent
c'est que vladimir poutine ne soit pris
à la tête de la russie mais vous savez
ce que la russie pour les admire poutine
à sa tête aujourd'hui vladimir poutine
était la tête de la russie donc on est
obligé de discuter avec lui c'est ce que
fait mme nelles macro semnan macron qui
appelle venir poutine pour le pousser à
la négociation pour le pousser à revenir
à la raison et pour arrêter les armes
parce que l'objectif c'est pas d'envoyer
des des incriminations c'est pas d'être
dans la surenchère verbale est
d'ailleurs monsieur macron n'est pas
dans la surenchère verbale il ne
qualifie pas verdien poutine du
dictateur il ne dit pas qu'il ya un
génocide en ukraine lui ce qu'il veut et
nous ce que nous souhaitons aussi c'est
que l'ukraine tout simplement voilé
soldats russes partir et que le peuple
ukrainien
alliés oui ou non mais c'est pas la
question de l'avenir poutine cela qu'ils
soient là comme si non une question
quand même se pose parce que vous saluer
le courage d'aider des ukrainiens et
leur force de ré de résistance mais en
même temps j'entends marine le pen qui
ne souhaite pas par exemple participer
ou aux envois d'armes létales alors j'ai
du mal d'ailleurs à saisir et ce qu'elle
veut envoyer sa des casques des
com a pu faire d'autres pays et qu'est
ce qu'elle entend par là et vous savez à
partir du moment où vous livrer des
armes à l'ukraine c'est à dire que vous
rentrez dans le conflit vous devenez qu
aux belligérants n'ont pas du tout si
c'est sûr que s'ils n'ont de fait
puisque de la l'heure actuelle le rock
envoie déjà des armes létales notamment
des missiles antichars et on n'est pas
considérée comme deco belligérants par
le ils ont coûté une écoute est il y a
une frontière qui est extrêmement mince
il faut soutenir l'ukraine et nous le
faisons notamment avec l'accueil des
réfugiés et on a été favorable dès le
début à l'accueil des réfugiés
ukrainiens qui sont des femmes qui sont
des enfants qui sont des personnes âgées
pour qu'ils puissent se mettre à l'abri
temporairement nous soutenons évidemment
le peuple ukrainien
je dirais donc ça dans sa résistance
monsieur me faut faire extrêmement
attention vous décernant à la fois les
dispositifs avril le pen présidente en
fait soutiendra l'ukraine mais ne
participera pas à toutes les sanctions
de sanctions édictées par l'union
européenne n'enverra pas d'armes létales
concrètement je ne vois pas en fait en
quoi elle soutient le peuple ukrainien
ont remis par les mots il n'y a pas que
des mots non les sanctions contre les
oligarques russes je pense que bon vent
dans le bon sens et surtout la meilleure
des aides c'est faire taire les armes
tout de suite c'est la négociation
comment on va sortir cette situation
sera uniquement par la négociation par
une grande conférence internationale
c'est pas par la guerre qu'on va régler
ce problème cette crise cette guerre
c'est véritablement à pousser la russie
revenir à la raison a poussé venir
poutine a arrêté cette invasion
d'ukraine alors autre question excusez
moi parce que je peux revenir sur les
propos de marine le pen hier qu'à parler
d'un rapprochement stratégique entre
l'otan et la russie sitôt le conflit en
ukraine achevée et traiter paix signés
déjà on est passé pas tout de suite tout
de suite mais alors j'imagine que par ce
rapprochement stratégique vous voulez
d'une certaine manière rechercher un
consensus des consultations des
décisions communes et des actions
communes c'est bien ça entre l'otan et
la russie où c'est avant la guerre en
ukraine y avait la volonté justement
d'un partenariat entre l'otan et la
russie cei avant alors aux jeunes avant
la guerre en fait cren excusé à une
volonté est là différent j'ai le
rapprochement stratégique que vous avez
que vous appelez de vos voeux c'est le
conseil otan-russie qui existe depuis
2002 non le relais en quoi serait-il
différent le rapprochement stratégique
mais vous savez là c'est très difficile
parce que la situation
aujourd'hui
empêche ce rapprochement et on va pas
par les
soldats russes le sont en ukraine et que
la russie bombardent des villes
ukrainiennes gère aujourd'hui ça n'a
aucun sens mais à terme il faut
évidemment que la russie redevienne un
partenaire il en va de la sécurité de
l'europe il en va de nos propres
intérêts vous savez avant marine le pen
souhaitait et d'ailleurs c'était pas la
seule emmanuel macron aussi quand il il
l'avait dit à venir poutine souhaitait
que la russie devienne un partenaire
pour lutter contre le fondamentalisme
islamiste comme c'est notre principale
au conseil otan russie qui a été créée
en 2002 à s'était évanoui d'une certaine
manière avec l'annexion de par la russie
de la crimée en 2000 en 2014 de fait ça
pose une question c'est à dire qu'est ce
que marine le pen ne doit pas pour
favoriser un rapprochement entre l'otan
et russie étant donné qu'il a disparu de
ce du fait de l'annexion aussi on
reconnaît que l'annexion de la crimée
était une erreur mais ce que vous parlez
vous parlez d'annexion et où un
référendum en crimée ya palm a été
reconnue par la communauté
internationale hier il ya eu un
référendum vous savez par qui il a été
reconnu en
référé sur les deux pays qui ont et
qu'ils ont connu
un référendum question yassir il n'y a
pas eu et si elle est excusez moi il n'y
a pas eu de flux de réfugiés une
craignent un venant de crime et parce
que tout simplement la crimée les
habitants se sentaient russe et qu'ils
ont à prouver que la crimée reviennent à
la russie c'est tout voilà nous avons
respecté le principe du référendum parce
que nous respectons la souveraineté des
peuples et notamment le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes une
dernière question sur le crâne d'une
heure
oui bien sûr sur l'ukraine j'imagine que
non sur l'otan voilà c'était plus sur le
temps que voulez vous
réinterrogée parce que là aussi hier
marine le pen a confirmé son souhait de
quitter le commandement intégré de
l'otan ce cas lorsqu'il fait qu'elle
reste dié la france resterait ligue et à
l'otan et donc à son article 5 1 qui
consacre le principe de défense
collective et dit qu'elles iront sera
pas la vrai nom sera pas mais d'un autre
façon et je ne peux pas dès lors qu' on
est en notant le temps mais je dès lors
je ne vois pas tellement l'intérêt de
quitter commandement intégré
expliquez-nous s'il ya un matériel bien
double intérêt
la position que ce soit marine le pen
c'était la position de la france entre
1966 et 2009 avant que nicolas sarkozy
décide donc de d'intégrer le
commandement intégré de l'otan très
clairement on a bien vu en 2003 que
l'indépendance avait du poids notamment
avec le refus de participer à
l'intervention américaine illégitime en
irak il est très important que la france
retrouve cette position et cette
vocation indépendante et ça ça passe
effectivement c'est pareil dit pit war
monsieur odoul un gardien en 2003
l'allemagne à la turquie qui me font
partie du le commandement intégré de
l'otan ont refusé aussi de participer à
l'opération militaire
en irak donc ça veut dire on n'est pas
obligé de quitter commandement intégré
pour se dissocier de la de la stratégie
italienne si c'est si bien sûr que si il
faut sortir de ce commandement intégré
le temps parce qu'elle inclut une sorte
de vassalisation il faut bien le dire
est que nos intérêts et surtout la place
et le message de la france n'est pas
perçue comme indépendante et singulier
c'est ça le problème vous savez quand
monsieur macro
pas question de quitter l'otan vous
savez entre 66 et 2009 y avait aucun
problème à respecter gérer les
engagements que nous avions au sein de
l'alliance atlantique ça n'a posé aucun
problème mais le commandement intégré
c'est encore autre chose et quand
monsieur macron est allé en russie
discutait avec monsieur poutine je pense
que la place de la france n'était pas
celle qui nous place indépendante et
plus celle d'un porte parole de l'otan
et donc par conséquent des intérêts
américains il faut que la france
redevienne une puissance d' équilibre et
donc ça passe par cette sortie du
commandement intégré de l'otan on va
parler de l'europe puisque puisque
marine le pen on a parlé également hier
et emmanuel macron on a parlé une et à
strasbourg mardi il a dit que cette
élection était aussi un référendum pour
ou contre l'europe et il a dit que
marine le pen des fontes est un projet
nationaliste il a repris la phrase de
françois mitterrand le nationalisme
c'est la guerre quand didot on a le
droit depuis le premier tour à toutes
les caricatures à tous les épouvantails
qui sont sorties les plus ridicules
j'observe qu'il ya un déluge de fausses
informations sur des retours sur des
libertés alors même que nos libertés
individuelles et collectives n'ont
jamais été aussi restreinte et aussi
émietté que soit mail macron trace à 100
il faut être sérieux dans ce débat là
avec marine le pen ça va être
véritablement un changement de politique
mais pour autant nos libertés sont
respectées
marine le pen en europe c'est plus le
moteur franco allemand mais
pourquoi il faut il faut il encore mais
il faut être pragmatique avec
l'allemagne poussait les français le
savent bien pour être dans un couple il
faut regarder dans la même direction
voilà le problème c'est que l'allemagne
ne regarde pas dans la même direction
qui regarde
d'autres papas que marine le pen c'est
marine le pen quand elle sera élue
présidente de la république française
elle représentera la france la france
deuxième pays d'europe la deuxième
économie d'europe donc elle est
respectée et elle aura énormément
d'allier et vous le savez et la france
ne sera pas en couple juste au cas où
j'allais dire elle sera célibataire et
indépendante parce qu'il faut garantir
les intérêts des français avant de voir
les intérêts d'autres pistes j'observe
que l'allemagne qui dont on dit à chaque
fois qu'elle parle d'europe qu'elle
défend l'europe etc que fait-elle
notamment pour son armée elle achète des
avions américains voilà elle ne favorise
pas l'industrie française et ça a
toujours été comme ça avec l'allemagne
parce que l'allemagne garantit les
intérêts des allemands tout simplement
alors que la france soit même macron a
beaucoup garantie d'intérêt des
allemands malheureusement sur sur la
coopération européenne j'avoue que j'ai
l'impression que marine le pen est quand
même sur un chemin de crête et j'en veux
pour preuve les mesures qu'elle compte
prendre qui risque de nous mettre en
porte-à-faux vis-à-vis des traités
européens alors vous connaissez comme
moi c'est de ses engagements par un
référendum pour la priorité nationale
risque d'être en contradiction avec les
certains traités internationaux dont le
traité l'union européenne et
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme mais je veux citer aussi
d'autres choses vous plaidez pour un
contrôle national des frontières des
marchandises pour éviter la fraude pour
résumer et des procès et vous voulez
mettre en place des prochaines
procédures j'ai du mal les procédures de
franchissement simplifiée pour les
citoyens des états de l'union européenne
c'est à dire que vous revoyez finalement
la circulation libre normalement des
biens et des personnes au sein de
l'union concrètement si ça ressemble pas
un vrai exit ça ressemble à quoi
mais en fait nous souhaitons et marine
le pen souhaite que les français restent
maîtres chez eux et que les français
puissent contrôler le destin et
les ancrer dans d'autres comme dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs d'autres pays
qui sont souverains nous voulons
récupérer nos souverainetés d'ailleurs
le premier déplacement de marine le pen
sera à bruxelles pour négocier avec la
commission européenne qui devra j'allais
dire qui sera obligé de négocier
pourquoi parce que oui le vrai vote
démocratique des français va s'imposer
c'est la volonté poppys s'impose pas à
la volonté pose c'est la volonté
populaire vous savez la france est une
grande puissance la france est la
deuxième économie de l'union européenne
et très sincèrement
beaucoup de peuples en europe aspire
aussi au retour de leur souveraineté à
la préservation de leur identité au fait
de contrôler l'immigration vous
je l'entends mais excusez moi marine le
pen appelle à se libérer du carcan de
bruxelles 1 je la cite afin de réformer
l'europe de l'intérieur mais si vous n'y
arrivez pas qu'est ce que vous faites
mais nous n'y arrive pas ce que ça vous
savez c'est une négociation ils sont pas
obligés d'accepter vos conditions vous
savez le danemark fait ce que nous
voulons faire notamment avec les
demandes d'asile vers le gouvernement
danois est un gouvernement social
démocrate qui a souhaité que les
demandes d'asile soient effectués étudié
dans les pays de départ et non plus le
territoire danois c'est exactement ce
que nous voulons faire est-ce que c'est
incompatible avec l'union européenne
avec comment dirais-je
les traiter les traités européens le
danemark le fait et nous le ferons aussi
donc en fait faut dépassionner ce débat
faut dire que ça va pas être on va pas
dans une révolution on va tout
simplement dans une évolution où le
peuple français va retrouver la maîtrise
de ses frontières
la maîtrise de sa souveraineté la
primauté du droit français sur les
directives européennes c'est le bon sens
et ce sera décidé par une majorité de
français les primes donc marie le pen
aura la légitimité pour le faire
sur l'europe mais une autre difficulté
que j'ai pointé vous allez pouvoir
m'expliquer marine le pen veut réduire
de façon unilatérale la contribution
française au budget lui un de l'union
européenne de 3 à la dernière il ya un
mais alors le souci c'est que le budget
2021 et 2027 a déjà été adopté alors
comment vous faites ce sera sur l'autre
budget ce sera sur le dégel après donc
pour le prochain mandat de marine le pen
non
pas pour le prochain mandat de marine le
pen là il faut rappeler à nos
concitoyens que nous sommes des
contributeurs perdant dans cette affaire
parce que nous donnons énormément
d'argent et l'union européenne qui nous
en prend nous en recevons beaucoup au
titre de la deûle attaque oui très bien
sauf qu'il ya aussi une hypocrisie c'est
qu'on donne énormément d'argent l'union
européenne en garde et ensuite nous
redistribue via des fonds européens donc
via les régions directement qui
quémandent à
à bruxelles alors que c'est notre argent
avancé l'argent des français l'argent
des français doit servir les intérêts
français et nous considérons qu'il ya
des économies à faire sur ces
contributions julien dollon a parlé de
la réforme des retraites puisque ça
c'est un sujet qui inquiète les français
vous proposez vous me dites un âge de
départ à 60 ans si vous rentrez sur le
marché du travail avant 20 ans et à 62
ans si vous entrez sur le marché du
travail après est ce que ça veut dire
que si j'entre sur le marché du travail
à 19 ans dans un métier qui n'est pas
dur métier de bureau je partirai à la
retraite avant quelqu'un qui est dans un
métier difficile mais qui rentrent qui
commence à travailler à 23 ans oui le
principe c'est la retraite en bonne
santé parce que la retraite il n ya pas
une forme d'injustice
avait commencé à travailler tôt
l'immense majorité dans l'immense
majorité des cas ces des métiers manuels
c'est des métiers manuels qui nécessite
beaucoup de travail qui nécessite qu au
bout d'une vie de travail vous êtes
souvent cassés devait le dos cassé vous
avez les bras cassé et donc très
sincèrement il faut que vous puissiez
partir le plus tôt possible pour
bénéficier ses divas très fort bien sûr
mais si
vous êtes
à 22 ans vous commencez vous mais
attendez vous commencez à travailler
entre 17 et 20 ans la plupart du temps
dans l'immense majorité des cas ces des
métiers manuels c'est la réalité donc
vous avez vocation à partir plus tôt moi
j'observe que la réforme de monsieur
macron c'est à dire 65 ans parce que ça
a été confirmé par monsieur attal même
si le petit revirement de monsieur mâcon
pour jeter du lest à la gauche ce sera
65 ans ça c'est la retraite casse et
c'est à dire que d'une part c'est un
principe qui va pénaliser les plus
faibles et les plus modestes parce que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé a
considérablement reculé du fait de
je dirais de de ce départ à la retraite
beaucoup plus tardif et puis ensuite
d'un point de vue économique à 62 ans
vous avez 50 % de nos concitoyens qui
sont au chômage et monsieur mais
plus de chômeurs c'est contradictoire
avec ce que vous dites puisque vous ne
tenez pas compte de la difficulté du
métier
vous supprimez le compte ce personnel de
prévention c'est à dire de la pénibilité
donc j'ai c'est vrai que je rejoins en
rien il ya quand même difficulté là
dedans c'est à dire que vous
reconnaissez vous ne prenez en compte
simplement que le démarrage de la de la
vie active il n'y a pas que ça il ya
aussi la pénibilité en soi du travail
l'individuation de cette pénibilité a
été essentielle pour calculer et pour
mesurer à la fin à quel âge on doit
partir non c'est un principe de justice
sociale tout simplement là vous avez
commencé à travailler tôt ap avec 40
annuités travaillez vous partez à 60 ans
vous avez commencé à travailler plus
tard avec 42 annuités vous partez donc à
partir de deux arrivées aussi vous
arrivez au pouvoir vous arrêter la
réforme touraine qui augmente
progressivement le nombre de trimestres
qu'on doit cotiser pour toucher une
retraite à taux plein ça a mis fin cette
réforme et le taux plein ça restera 67
ans le taux plein c'est 62 ans
à l'imiter travailler pour avoir une
retraite à taux plein donc si vous
commencez à travailler après 20 ans et
40 annuités travailler si vous avez
commencé à travailler entre 17 et 20 ans
renault intervient par exemple monsieur
au double vous aurez 42 annuités donc
vous terminerez à
jeter rémunéré tard j'ai commencé à
travailler donc la retraite à 62 ans
pour vous c'est juste une illusion non
mais excusez moi mais j'ai
commencé à travailler à 25 26 27 ans
mais oui pour avoir une retraite à taux
plein effectivement vous ne partirez pas
62 ans mais ça nos concitoyens le savent
le mot sur le pouvoir d'achat là aussi
c'est important de préoccupation
première des français votre menu phare
c'est de baisser la tva sur une liste de
lui est là aussi vous savez que les
produits éligibles à la tv à la baisse
de la tva ils sont encadrés par l'union
européenne comment vous faites dans
l'immédiat du coup ce qui est nouveau ce
qui est incroyable c'est que avec vous
mais avec la macro ni en fait on ne peut
rien faire
avec vous et avec l'ama il y avait 1 et
7 6 6 6 en fait on ne peut rien faire
l'union européenne va tout bloquer
excusez-nous le conseil faisait beau
mais c'est logique vous savez quand le
peuple le jeu le peuple ne peut donc le
encore une fois la baisse de la tva qui
est une nécessité 20% à 5 5 sur les
produits énergétiques
c'est la seule manière pérenne de
redonner de l'argent aux français voilà
c'est tout il y en a pas d'autre c'est
pas d'échec c'est pas des ristournes
comme le fait monsieur macron mais tout
simplement 150 à 200 euros de pouvoir
d'achat par mois à chaque ménage et
aussi les 100 produits de première
nécessité qui aujourd'hui donc sont des
produits de base les pâtes le riz les
produits d'hygiène qui aujourd'hui sont
le reste à vivre vous à l'ag est-ce que
vous avez chiffré le coût de cette
mesure tout du milliard d'euros 12
millions d'euros pour la baisse de la
tva effectivement tva avec les produits
énergétiques ou simplement les paniers
de première nécessité douze milliards
d'euros c'est pour la baisse de la tva
sur les produits énergétiques
j'ajoute que c'est cette mesure est
totalement
financé puisque marine le pen créera
notamment un ministère de lutte contre
la fraude sociale et ce sera un minimum
de 15 milliards d'euros qui sera
récupérée sachant qu'ils aient des
rapports parlementaires du sénat qui
évalue entre 15 milliards d'euros par an
et 45 milliards d'euros lé montant de la
fraude sociale les ans je veux
simplement citer qu'eux peut-être
pourrez-vous réagir lieu le cabinet
asterès cabinet d'experts économiques et
à qui a chiffré la mesure pour
concernant les produits de baignade
première nécessité à peu près 4
milliards pour un gain
effectif pour les foyers de 13 euros par
an un cabinet conseil encore
avec encore d'accord donc ça le
disqualifie le fait de femmes et fameux
conseil en fait qui disent qu'il ne faut
rien faire et qu'il ne faut surtout pas
rendre de la vivre français il a quand
même pas notre philosophie ce projet
d'accord il nous reste une minute trente
l'autre question vous le savez un client
interroge les français c'est avec qui va
gouverner marine le pen pourquoi il
refuse de donner le nom de son premier
ministre
marine le pen déjà va gouverner que le
peuple français et ça va changer
voie du référendum article le 11 et
aussi par la voie du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui va permettre
aux français de se saisir de sujets de
déclencher des faire des référendums et
d'agir en fait dans la vie démocratique
de notre pays chose qui n'a jamais été
fait
elle aura un premier ministre donne
évidemment oui je vous le
donne et non parce que aucun président
de la république sauf exception avait
donné le nom son
premier ministre avant l'élection en
2010 cette désunion de nicolas du
contenu parce qu'il y avait un accord
qui était qui et je dirai qui sortait
d'une situation politique mais très
clairement là l'objectif c'est pas de
vous donner un casting l'objectif c'est
de rassembler un gouvernement d'union
nationale avec des personnalités qui
partagent des orientations de marine le
pen qui auront à coeur perdu
notre pays mais qui parce que par
exemple eric zemmour il a il a tout de
suite appelé à voter marine le pen
devant du premier tour marion maréchal
pareil et pourtant elle dit non ils ne
seront pas dans mon gouvernement
pourquoi mais c'est pas la question du
casting j'ose dire vous savez vous avez
des personnalités éminentes qui
travaillaient que marine le pen qui ont
contribué à la réalisation de son projet
projet d'ailleurs qui est très très peu
attaqué par nos adversaires parce qu'il
est chiffré parce qu'il est crédible
parce qu'il est sérieux et ces
personnalités auront vocation à entrer
au gouvernement mais la grande nouveauté
très sincèrement il est quand même
attaqué la grande personnalité qui va
entrer au gouvernement c'est le peuple
français l'expert qui n'a jamais été
consulté par macron c'est le peuple
français et lui participera à la
direction de notre pays est né à la
pression oui bien sûr si on peut pas
savoir exactement les négociations
autour du gouvernement est ce que vous
devrez quand même des discussions avec
eric zemmour concernant les législatives
mais je sais que ça passionne donc les
comment dirais-je
les aimer les législatives jacent second
temps on verra ça après l'élection du 20
au 24 avril
l'objectif déjà c'est de se rassembler
c'est de permettre la victoire de marine
le pen c'est d'empêcher le maquereau
nisme de se poursuivre et donc c'est
d'opérer le plus large rassemblement de
tous les français qui veulent plus de
pouvoir d'achat qui veulent une retraite
digne en bonne santé qui veulent moins
d'immigration qui veut plus de sécurité
donc c'est la victoire de marine le pen
qui permettra tout ça c'est l'enjeu du
24 avril merci hugo houle merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité porte parole du
rassemblement national soutien de marine
le pen on regarde la une de la voix du
nord c'est but tony but tony sous haute
surveillance oui à la lutte avec
perquisitions tout temps merci beaucoup
merci j'ai bien sûr
[Musique]